today we're going to talk about how to
figure out if you have this very
specific type of vertigo
and what to do about it and it's called
benign
paroxysmal positional
vertigo this is the type of vertical
that will make you feel like you're
spinning okay when you're not spinning
so the word benign means not dangerous
the word paroxysmal means a sudden
increase of a symptom and the word
positional means something related to
motion of your head and vertical means
feeling like you're spinning when you're
not really spinning so in this video
we're just going to name it B ppv and
this is the number one cause of
dizziness and what's normally causing
this condition is a calcium Crystal that
is broken off and it's in the canals of
the inner ear the ones that are
controlling equilibrium and keeping
things balanced so this little piece of
calcium crystal is kind of floating in
there and it's interfering with the
little hairs and it's giving you this
Sensation that is um not correct it's
like you're moving when you're not
moving or you're spinning when there's
no spinning going on so later in this
video I want to talk about why this
calcium is there in the first place and
how to get rid of it but first let's
talk about how to figure out if you have
this condition and what side it's coming
from is the problem on the left side or
the problem on the right side so in this
first test to determine if you have it
and what side it is this is called the
Dix Hall Pike test but you're going to
basically do this maybe on your bed or a
table with a pillow okay and you're
going to quickly lower your body in a
Supine position so you're laying face up
and you can have a pillow underneath
your upper back so your head can tilt
back because you want your head extended
like 30 degrees
backwards over the horizontal so you
want this pillow underneath your
shoulders so the first thing you're
going to do is you're going to turn your
head to the right about 45 degrees okay
now if you truly have this bppv you will
experience not just dizziness that you
will experience the stigmas now that's a
condition where your eyes can move back
and forth horizontal vertical or they
can rotate but if you have nystigmas as
well as dizziness chances are you have
this condition now this does help to
have someone observing you to tell you
if that's happening but maybe if there's
no one around maybe you have a a mirror
and you're looking at your eyes but just
realize too before you do any of these
tests check with your doctor make sure
you don't have some type of cervical
spine problem where you can't rotate
your neck very much so that's my
disclaimer okay so once you've done this
to the right side then you'll repeat
this exact same procedure looking to the
left side and so you're usually going to
find one side that's going to be
involved so let's pretend the problem is
on going to the right side okay then
we're going to do the next part and this
is more of a treatment so what we want
to do is we want to create different
motions to slowly move this little
calcium Crystal
out of this canal okay that's the goal
of this procedure and it's called the
Epley maneuver and you would do it on
whatever side that you have this problem
with okay so we're pretending it's the
right side so first thing you're going
to do okay is you're going to turn the
head to the affected side so we're going
to turn it to the right side okay about
45 degrees and extend it about 30
degrees and you're going to hold this
position for about one minute now
chances are you are going to experience
symptoms when you're doing this okay so
after a minute of holding this position
now you're going to turn your head to
the opposite side
about 45 degrees and hold that position
for one minute now what you're doing is
you're slowly dislodging this calcium
Crystal
through this canal with the intention of
pushing it out to the other end okay now
what you're going to do is you're going
to roll on the shoulder and maintain
your chin tucked down to your shoulder
and so you're going to be looking
downward at a 45 degree angle and you're
going to hold this for about 30 seconds
again the reason why we're doing this is
to allow this little calcium Crystal to
keep moving through the canal and the
last thing you're going to do is you're
going to sit up with your head kept
rotated with your chin tucked toward the
shoulder
and then you're going to slowly rotate
your head back to normal now hopefully
this calcium Crystal has moved out of
this little canal and you feel much
better this particular treatment should
only be done once a day and you're going
to keep doing it until your symptoms
resolve okay so what's really Behind
These calcium crystals building up
that's the next Topic in a 2020
systematic review and meta-analysis
they found some really interesting
association between
bppb and a vitamin D deficiency in this
review those people that had that
condition were twice as deficient in
vitamin D as the rest of the group you
see vitamin D helps in the absorption of
calcium and this calcium is dislodged in
the lymphatic little tubes in the inner
ear so obviously it didn't get absorbed
so we have a more concentrated calcium
in that area and chances are this is due
to a vitamin D deficiency vitamin D also
helps in the transportation of calcium
as well in another study I found there
was a 5.5 times more likely risk of
developing
bppv and yet another study I found that
bppv was substantially decreased if the
person took more vitamin D now in
another study I found bppv was 23 times
more likely to occur if someone was
deficient in vitamin D 23 times that's
crazy so apparently vitamin D is the
answer for this condition I will say
there were some studies that did not
show that this condition had any problem
with vitamin D deficiency in the blood
and I understand I think the reason for
that is this there is a genetic
component to this problem many many
people have a problem with
the vitamin D receptor now a person
could have a situation where they have
normal vitamin D in the blood
but not in the tissues because of the
receptor is downgraded because of some
genetic mutation just because someone
has a normal vitamin D level in their
blood doesn't always tell you the whole
picture I mean this also relates to
other things like insulin resistance
when some people have insulin resistance
they might have high insulin in the
blood yet very low insulin in the cells
this is why many symptoms of even
diabetes are related to a deficiency in
insulin even though they have this
massive amount of insulin in the blood I
mean the same thing goes with cortisol
the stress hormone too a person can have
this high level of cortisol in the blood
yet have all the symptoms of a cortisol
deficiency right I mean cortisol is
supposed to get rid of inflammation why
would they end up with this huge amount
of inflammation when they have high
amounts in the blood well now you know
the problem is in the receptor so the
same thing with vitamin D you can't
always go with what's going on in the
blood so what what am I recommending as
a solution I'm recommending you do
vitamin D and I'm also going to
recommend you add vitamin K2 because
vitamin K2 is also involved in
transporting calcium out of soft tissue
so this is what I would do instead of
taking a daily dose of vitamin D3 and K2
I would do this I would take five days
of that dosage and take it all at once
because both of these vitamins vitamin
K2 and vitamin D are fat soluble so
they'll get absorbed in the body and
they'll get slowly released when your
body needs it but there's some
interesting data that shows that if you
do sometimes take your vitamin D
erratically or not every day
consistently there's a little bit better
results so what does this mean well you
would take
50 000 IUS of vitamin D3 so if you find
vitamin D tablets in 10 000 IUS just
take five of those okay hopefully you'll
also find one that has the K2 in the
right ratio and the right ratio meaning
for every 10 000 IUS of D3 you want a
hundred micrograms of K2 so in this
situation you would take 50 000 IUS of
vitamin D3 and 500 micrograms of K2 and
basically you just take this dose once a
week now just because vitamin D is so
important
I created another video to show you all
of the reasons why you might be
deficient and what to do to overcome
that and I put that video up right here
check it out